Shawn Johnson was the first Olympic
gymnast to win Dancing with the Stars so
the big question is now will lori
hernandez be the next well if I was a
bettin man let me tell you I mean they
got the whole package really including
the highest scores of any couple so far
and they are working hard to keep it
that way
that's how you do the first two weeks on
Dancing with the Stars ladies and
gentlemen you guys rocked it absolutely
look it they can't stop they can't they
just keep going it's unbelievable it's
unbelievable
can we just bottle up the cuteness of
these two I mean who else warms up like
this and let's not forget she is just 16
years old and loving the dancing perks
how are you enjoying that aspect the
heels the glitter the show with the
audience all of that all of it it's a
lot it's why is he laughing right now
I mean like for the Olympics we did our
own makeup and that was something that
we really looked forward to doing like
our own hair own makeup like here they
do all your makeup they do your hair
they get you fitted for all these
awesome outfits and when somebody's
going to get you your coffee in the
morning
she's also bonded with all of her fellow
competitors and even comforted Ryan
Lochte when he and Cheryl were in
jeopardy how is he feeling you chat with
him he said he's really excited to just
move on and be able to show another
week's full of Dance
so yeah did you have any like words of
encouragement I gave my hose you gave my
now Laurie and Val are perfecting their
tango hoping to hang on to that top spot
and they'll be using that tango Monday
night is the heads up competition that's
where two couples dance at the same time
against each other
Lori and Val will be pitted against
Marilu Henner and Derek Hough to the top
teams right there
have you waved back